[Musik]
das ist R Waldhorn auf der
bner
der2 me h Berg im Quellgebiet vom hinter
ist
v wo
[Musik]
Ursprung
bis nach
müigolgt den auf der zweite der
rie g Strom FL
V so bis es n wiangen
[Musik]
ist tut mir
leid g in Nordsee mit dem R oder ins
Mittelmeer ich
hab dem Wasser auf die andere se vom
raldorn nach und dem Desin s
Wasserperlen
entdecken vor der 26 Kanton g aus z von
der schwitz aberus
wasserparadiesere Etappe von sü Wied
zurück ich Waldhorn im Bezirk PL
triier Bezirk lugan und mendrio bevor
zum Lago maore geht Dur centovallizas
und
ma schlussendlich auf n
Pass Waldhorn
auf
hier se de Berg Adula versch B so wie
das da trag Wasser
aber und da beweg ich mir auf der erste
Etappe von der entdecksreis vom Fuß vom
Adula bis zu der Quelle von
Brenno geht aber nach
aquarossa nach Leon
[Musik]
geh das ist Gebiet Bren und vom
Lukmanier Pass da triff man auf 200
Millionen Jahr die meeresablagerige a
und hier entspringt die er die
wasserperle der brenn das Wasser W hier
F gestoss wird h auf M besonders die
wirkig so wie z. auf Erfolgsautor Fabio
Andina CIA
[Musik]
Fabio
F
intiio
quagente F Brenno fen che il Fal più
important
dileurslich ist Fabius
Lugano
ando questa fess'è questa
fessaellaoc l'qu eoa ma da do arriva
Quest
questoante ma Poss dire che
500 Fiume asiatico perché no e se io
allora tocco
quest'acqua posso fare un ragionamento e
dire io ho toccato
qualcuno che ha toccato la stessa acqua
la stessa particella
dell'acqua an FA da qu
altrate me Quest cosascina il F
che tramite l'qua no siamo connessi con
der Brenner FHT langsam aber
ist ab und zu G Blick Adula übrigens der
H Berg vom Kanton Dach vom tin
wie FSE
per
ma l'acqua di quel ghiacci andrà
sicuramente a formare un'altra Perla o
Tante altre Perle da qualche parte n
[Musik]
questoisisoossa W der 1950er bis 7
international bekannte Kurort ist zuf
hte eig die thermal und fangquelle mit
besonders hö mineralkalt geführt ob der
Fabi die Region kennt wie S hosasche ist
noch nie
hier fangoschlam hätte heilen die wirk
und hilft besonders berumatische
erkrankige wenn
das und we man
grif
ck
[Musik]
Luft ist so licht es ist
so
erst Kontakt mit Luft lagert sich aus
dem Quellwasser er galartige fangomasse
ab früher hier trink durführt im Fall V
kreislaufstöge oder Blutarmut
mehr we spezielle Wasser einfach n
[Musik]
probieren revitalisiert geht V aquarossa
nach leontika
Fabio Roman Tage mit fel F das
ist j morgen EG Wetter auf hberg und das
B nimmt
bes
ber mit dem Filmwissenschaftler und
schriftstell machen der Weg der F gangen
ist auf them Fabias bur erre F
lieblingsbach der Fabi identifiziert
sehr
meno cose hai menoensieri hai per la
testa questo è già un primo passo verso
la felicità e poi la felicità la TR
quando
vadoeg Inti come questi no e la TR nel
silenzio
p
Passi
perare rire
interiore irgendwen met das
Wasser bewusst wie se das Wasser mit dem
Rest von der wel
verbundenz
[Musik]
Fira marce
tir qualo immo Nell in giro per il
mondo sie andere we wasserperlene und
doch finde sie irgendwen wieder
Z zweite Etappe geht von BL Riviera
vaskaus konzentriere auf schluchte
berera und
irania EG wir Wasser da abwärts und
verlat W blen richtig
Süde in biaska vereint sich der Brenno
mit dem desiner Hauptfluss diino in
dicht bebaut Ort ergie sich am Hang
überm Bahnhof Santa petronilla Wasserau
der wieder mit Fabio abgemacht ohne
gebürtig büner Wasserparadies des nicht
ganz chlie der 4jährig physiotherape
expert in Sache
extremport
fa le Wasserparadies oberh V Stadt W
wirklich bekannt aus Perle kan man sagen
oder ja das kann man wirklich so
se schön zum B es hat n se oder sols num
240 auch schön n so
wunderschön nicht unbedingt
ja das ist langwiig und
h im kalte Wasser zum schwz bringen komm
K okay los geht's mit dem Canyoning
abentür für das braucht man V neenzug
mit entsprechend
Schuhe g mit karabin Fürze und der Hel
und den muss man
mallaufen sind Orte wo man so einfach
nicht nicht Wasser ist immer schön
Wasser ist ja le Wasser der
Fabi das freundlich Schlucht
fürfang
schön die schö wasserf das ist traumhaft
abere Angst der Finger
ma einfach so sehr
unbehaufenestellt und sehr unbehoff
[Musik]
gefühlt danst ein Vorteil wenn man Angst
hat dann passt man
[Applaus]
auf
Co ist schossump und Rü
[Musik]
canoning das ist jetzt lustig
aberstrengend trotzd Fabi sie geh parat
für eine gr
herusforder
Schlucht es F da mit 14 m
Sprung und der 40 m ABS
[Musik]
Challenge wirklich überlet ich abbre
aber denkt das kann ich nicht machen es
ist HCH und jetzt musst
du
ja es
istich Komis
Gefühl okay lieber
Gott
und ke Wand mehr Fu nicht
weg
ma
irgendwie mus
ab stell die nicht so muss mit dir
sauber
reden Wasser
brating
out of my comfort
zone dank Fabio zu erfah Wasser
Riv
[Musik]
schö die find im
Süden dr
et Nord vom
und hier im sü se Grund
mon undter
berget Monte Tamaro führt mitis nach
Lugano und den auf Etappe 4 im
südlichste Gebiet von der schwitz
bruzella mache Abstecher nach
Mendrisio nach meride und
Ende in Riva San
Vitale vor der
[Musik]
gut auf Monte
Tamaro Santa
mariaangeli
entworfen vom Tessiner Stararchitekt
Mario Botta V dem Berg Z wier aber
Wasser vom Lago di
[Musik]
Lugano in Lugano zum ersten Mal das
mediterran FL vom
DIN
irgendwo oder brasilie der Mon s
Salvadore Erin
aber tatsächlich
Schwiz immer wieder dem
Land weg vom See
Zentrum ST die ganz sicher nicht doch
gemde hin huswand Aufmerksamkeit dieige
Wandmalerei KST
neverell KST Christian
rebeck neverw so promin stad platert mit
dem verhautnis ZS
und Christian ti perare
questteo cheatteris princiale possa
essereiderio di di comunicare anche di
di confrontarsi perché alla fine l'arte
in generale in un certoenso è bisog
un'urgenza di comunicare ma nstro caso
c'è
anche il fatto di farlo all'interno
dello spazio in cui vivono altre persone
quindi c'è un confronto molto diretto la
Balena comunque esistendo in tutto il Mo
in tutti gli oceani in specie diverse
rpresenta un po' anche
uneriment per quello che è lo Stato
dellaa perché la Benis ANC oggi l'omo
anche se in
modii
Colas per industrieartisti ist der Grund
von der never Word der Christian undund
pablo5st Lugano KT und sie s
Team flüs
garate
[Musik]
und neverw wir
immeranut erare achi metri distan che
abamo da qui dal g èo dei fiumi più Anti
mondo che per loro è sacro però malgrado
questo è un Fiume che è stato distrutto
dall'inquin arare questa
kticit in
L seito il mon
vol
Pass sì è verissimo ci sono tantissime
bellezze diamo esperienze Ticinesi che
proprio perché sono vicine che a volte
si
dannout
[Musik]
Grazie Panorama auf einzigartige
wasserweltg V stad undterzicht der
aze Christian rebecki wei wie witig
soblick persön
Arbeit credo che sia importante
continuare a mantenere la
consapevolezza di quello che che si fa e
di quello che succede intorno e anche
mantenere diciamo attiva la critica nei
confronti dei sistemi a cui siamo
abituati anche delle delle comoditài
siamo abituati perché chiaramente le
comodità che abbiamo arrivano da
f Christian s gedan Pass gut zumfang V
der nächste Etappe im Süden vom Lago di
[Musik]
Lugano der
südlichsteuslä entlang im mot findet Ort
W der Mensch versucht der Natur ke
schrichten
geb
F fl
der Park mit der schluchte und Wasser
ist
geschüzt die Fels offenbare Ural die
geologische Geschicht war
frühärisch steichte vor Jahr Millionen a
ablagerige in der grüne Schlucht
unterwegs auf M V
bruzella war vi settig verwunchen ört
kennt ist die renommierte Schauspieler
gardi hter die berühmtest die Clownin
von
Schwiz g im vorespr hast du mir schon
gest dass du mir die keps nicht was
verraten ja ich fin ke und schön muss
jeder selber entdecken W verhinder dass
der noch ke plözlich vol servler ist
sonder aber entdecken sie sind
zugänglich gter 37 Jahre im soer sie
froh sichil v
klar also ich B ein weniger spektakulär
landschaftlich wieere der
Vorteil und das find ich natürlich halt
viel schöner
aber schöne
Keim mit mit und
Wasserfall
naturleb sehr
intakt alle die mut mitör ist wie eine
schatzuhe auswärme irgendwenn der zit
B es paar Kilometer tauwärts richtig
mendris zeigt sich schon anders Bild
Zivilisation macht sich breit der
Umstand versuchen man zu korrigieren in
dem unterm straßengwi wieder Natur
landschaftsrüm schafft Sowi im Bach LaVo
also g diewartet D du mir so
ganz ehrlich ja das ist wirklich
Unort wo man der Industrie wieer Natur
abotzt ich fin ein sch Projekt also du
kan jetzt Stab B duach laufen das ist v
alles zu das ist ein Industrie Autobahn
Zug es ist wo man mE
Kontrast Verbindig nach stfind zwischen
der Zivilisation und und der Natur und
ich find da da wirklich g gchaff ich bin
dankbar dafür man muss man
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
per am v sehrer im DF meride der Monte
Sorg get aus eine der BÜ fstelle für
Marini Fossilie UNESCO naturerb hier im
Fossilienmuseum re 240 Millionen Jahr
zurück her nämlich F 50 Jahr g die hter
aus Clown komediantin gestartet dus mit
fein
aufg
ich
biis und m das so D s son ver nicht
auf die mehrfachzeichn die0jährige G
eine von der
international schwezer Künstlerin sie a
Frau der Comedyszene Pionierarbeit
gistet in dem Moment wirklich
welto
nicht
ne das freut mich al bin ich
stolz undter am Fuß vom Monte San
Giorgio Lied er Witter Schatz von der
Region Baptisterium in Riva San Vitale
aus dem 5 jahrhundert
e christliche Bauwerk in der
[Musik]
Schwiz bist du und ich bauft ich nichtft
warum h nicht TFT will ichusirr bin in
dem Rum inen fühle ich mich verbunden
mit et größerem wie man Demmer seit aber
in Kir oder immer Kathedrale ich immerüh
der Gott mir um Macht wer hat
s und ich meine ich ich kann ein
kirhören wo so viel Frau verachtig inen
ist aber was mir FT ich w z.B extrem
gern am sonag mor singen mit mit mit
anderen L
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
was göttlichet verbindet Gard und me
nliche Philosophie mir Spiritualität V
der
Natur vor
undutobahnfloss fürt la Riv vitale
südlichkt vom
luganers und von da geht's wieder zurück
richtig
Norden mit bedüsvle Orte Hinger auf
montegambaronno offenbart Panorama über
Lago maore s zurück im sopra
[Musik]
Cheri 200 Sonnenstunde im Jahr die
wärmste die Stadt von der schwitz unter
nördlich Ort mit mediterranem Klima
da Perle am lag maore larno ist der
Hauptort von me Bezirk mit 18 Geminde
mit dem SE verle Gebiet ganz besonder
Scharm de
vita direkt Lago maore f die Etappe
Minusio ma
Delta den nachon und
die Bahnhof in larno es geht über und in
Tran bis die italienische
[Musik]
grenzeanno
minio mit der ehemalige Miss schwitz aus
dem
jahr81 Brigit Foss es ist wichtiger Ort
für
se hier in minio ja
ich
ja hier gewt
direkt
und natürlich auch hier ganz schöne zit
mit stebra mit
Verner Brigit F ist 8 Jahr lang mit dem
liedsäer von der Schwizer Rockband
Gotthart Steve
Lee im
Oktober geminsam Trip
Amerika verlor wie präent
le
Herz und ich teile
fre nicht
unterschätz
n nach jah im brigited zurückz
undolgt
dieze sich
mediumer storbene über natatürliche
Frequenz wie sie seid sie offenbart mir
ih in Schatz ja also ich hat das ja
schon mal was als Kind und denn ich hat
das von me Großvater
GT und denn ist das be mir zueschüttet
wordde zum Teil der Schul und nach eine
min
prüfon und me der Vater von me Kinder
wunderbare Mensch aber mit der
Spiritualität hät nicht so also bei ihm
ich einfach wirklich das M
sehr mir mit dem
Steve wenn
ich erkl was ich wnme du Punkt
bringen so unkonventionelle Mens wie
Brigit faszinieren m sie se von Mens l
und sie glaub die
frü für das R Platz ma Delta direkt
Wasser ich bin jetzt ganz gut mit Seele
verbunden ich Füle dir
Ural Schmerz Brig frü aus
freiheitslebende und unbekümmerte
indianerbur b d ander stammff wir
und minut
ter und ich Füle das genau verlustchmerz
her ganz wichtig dass du das Schmerz den
wird zwischen menchliche le viel schöner
und besser
flüß Berner beschribt me bildhaft noch
viel mehr vergangene Ignis
wie und
Z Brigit
Element
wenn du möchtest kannst du mir jetzt
Frage stellen sehr viel
Informationen irgendwie Versuch
zuord das glaube W ich von der Brigit
gehört oder nicht l so seig for auf
[Musik]
reflektier haft Ambiente
klingen
Promenade PLZ Restaurant direkter mit
der Aussicht das ist
Luxus ach wie
schön Bri spirituell mench Kent aber weß
von
Geschichte passt du das passt sogar sehr
gut das gehört einfach zum zuum und ich
Genüße jed Moment
und so bin ich einfach happy und jetzt
ich
jetzt dass diejährige mit dem
südländischen FL sehr gut identifizier
da Italian wie viel Itali steckt dir oh
ganz
viel
Temperament ruhiguck ma und
binitalienerin
immer wieder
die kom
do kzert ja
unbedingt mit der Brigit Foss Tag am
Wasser vom Lago maore für meh
interessante Kombination von
[Musik]
Energie
neue Tag neue Geschicht und neue Strecke
W
bevorstehtarno am
bahnhofent
expressentina wie liebevoll
nen B
italienisol so geht aber
nichtent und was
best Nina
Dimitri CIA n wie geht ja es geht
gut im Herz ja aber ziemlich
verwunum was passiert aber meistens
mitnimmtum das Gut
D Tochter V berüm
schwierownmit und mit
[Musik]
sieag
nicht
Lieblingsinstrument
die
mitang LE und dasang das wirklich
ger bin
ichl
Zug
fah hier
wird sege zweite
[Musik]
wi das Dorf geh kulturell Schatz aus
Perle
Centovalli hier h Nina ihr
vater7 theat Dimitri
eröffnet im Sommer 2016 gestorben
die
teren du bist jetzt
da das Kulturzentrum
Famil
Theater sondern komikmuseum und
theaterhochschul international Ruf lockt
Schauspiel begeister die aus der ganze
wel
Dorf Legende vom Dimitri LT hier wier s
Werk mit dem gich Spirit Versuch Z Herf
ich
immer HGE weiß nicht
aber ist ist nicht einfach
das für sin aber trotzdem auf ne Art das
das
[Musik]
war es ist großes Dimitri
hinterl
vi vorher erste erste Programm gemacht
Nummer entwickelt mit groß Rollschuh und
roll
rpielt und dann hätte genau die
ein große rollchau und große
Roll
wirklich genau ich GLB sind
Inspiration wi V geht's nach intrania es
ist Dorf mit dem hchurm
V
mitlickang mit G
sin sch
zweprachigach sch und
dagen madna Mia quantiicordi
s terribile per meevopre mal di
pcia rid sem
perché ptinat il Dimitri cos Pella
pentola pentola qu
cosella sì eravate conosciute qua nel
centalli no come gruppo di bambini della
famiglia
Dimitri sì ma anche quello non era
sempre in favore perché ci chiamavano i
pagliacci smettila di fare dimitrina
dimitrina era ancora carino Dimitra sì
sì sì ma basta fare Clown cioè non non
non io me ne
Frio non mi
cosens in Tran l und Stiege
ganzo aber zum Ponte
Romano
istort
dieistisch Norm
g N und mas
naturpol
aber
unbedingt ja und
nicht bevor zu der letzte Perle von der
dimitr im Cent
geht wi mit
[Musik]
derent l von der dimitr ab und ganz
ver W
alle schö Kindheit g das hat mich sehr
prtort aber dann nachher später W ich
den alleid und alle sind schon die
jüngste ausflogen das da in der Nacht
Angst Meter im
Theater und bis morgen
sie und drum bin ich da und n immer sehr
sch immer so und wo sie
singe sind einfach wer ist das das ist
wie WoW ganut wirklich Nina hier ist der
Ort wo du h mit dem
charangop so schön wenn man der Tag
klingen mit mit Musik ja ma ich sehr
gern
[Musik]
йor
und
andere und zwar
was
berümis nach
BR
al
[Musik]
bisch überleende s gut erkennbar
voras ST von der HCH ST V Europa sie
bildet der lagogorni und S Wasser stammt
aus Fluss
wzaska ganz
him am
Hang
typischörf charakteristisch
[Musik]
für mit ein von der bekanntest Personen
aus dem
Desin das dörf mit de verwinkelte g
istes
Labyrint hier kann man sich
ver drum erlaub
[Musik]
mir
[Gelächter]
super hey es ist das erste Mal dass ich
in koripo bin und ich freue mich so sehr
es ist so schön es hat so viele
wunderschöne Häuser alles a Holz und
Steine und und die Ruhe hörst du etwas
nuras flie
wzaska hier man zum ersten Mal die
schmale schluchte mit besondere
Felsformation Kunstwerk wie n Natur
schaffen 4 km flusswärs kom eine von der
berühmt im ganz
[Musik]
des eine der schönsten Perlen im ganzen
Tessin ja der bekannteste Ponte sal oder
das ist natürlich eine touristische
Attraktion für alle und nicht nur für
die Touristen sondern auch für die
einheimische also ich bin immer gerne
hier und seit bald 40
Jahren schau mal wie schön die
einzigartige fslandschaft besteht a blö
V knis Granit Quarz und fabad vor der
Flur über jusig blank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
geschliffe ist unglaublich schön aber es
gibt auch andere Bilder wo dieser Ort
überfüllt ist mit Menschen oder ab Mitte
Juli bis Mitte August hier ist natürlich
überfü der Hochsaison tlich dur wask für
Stück Paradies influenzer aus
Norditalien prort aus malediv vand und
sorge für eine zusätzlich
touristenbom chr das Paradies oh Tourist
Ort mit kristallklarem Wasser
[Musik]
lieb wie ist das Wasser ist frisch es
ist sehr frisch ja aber gut also
nächstes Mal ma ich das auchätte ich
nicht dies Event nachher das ist Grund
warum muss ich moderieren und nasse
Haare ist nicht so gut oder eine gute
Ausrede die ehemalige mit schwitz ST im
Job aus Moderatorin se
unterwegs Schwiz
verchusswendig neninesgliosa
inant Bello es in sizzera perio nella
valas
per positiva riesco a ricaricare le
batterie unogo ini vengo spesso mi piace
essere qui ma per me la particolarità
del Ticino è proprio di essere Piccolo
Bello caldo
accogliente proprio di essere in vacanza
tutto l'anno per questo vivo in
Ticino die
prominenteere
Attraktion wir
immerin nur Frauen
weg vom
hotspoto
Bosco chr gern mit ihr und zwe um am
wanderwag entlang mit und riesige murm
SP scheiße aus der Sonn in der ganze
Schwiz bekannt
KR immer wieder
ich habe
auch
einige einiges erlebt und die schwierige
Momente die traurige Momente die zeige
ich natürlich nicht in der
Öffentlichkeit die behalte ich für mich
oder das heißt aber nicht dass bei
Christa immer alles gut läuft und chra
immer happy ist aber ich finde eben das
ist nicht mein Job das gehört nicht der
Öffentlichkeit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Sache W bewegig setzt kann man nicht
immer
stüren im Fluss vom le sanft ma KPF
ström Sonnin ist g Schum
FLW
ad
brii
Fam leg
per unter prion no ser schm
öffnetas Wasserperlen geht
da wass SP
mits
frü get wir poenta
produziert ist unsere Mühlemann also die
Mühle gehörte sein Familie und jetzt er
mit seine Tochter und mit der ne sie sie
machen das weiter die
tradition5ade
dran
das in bertaska da war und das war für
den Hotel und dann auch für einige
Häuser in sonono und frasco aber nur
eine Glühlampe pro Haus nur wenn Wasser
da
war Kraftwerk und müllig gehöre zum
Ethnographische Museum Wal wzaska wo im
letzte Dorf vom wzaskatal liedt von hier
stammt auch dein Familienname genau
sononini kommt von sonono und sononini
ist eine der älteste Familie von
V Ort bist du duuf stolz ja meine
wurzstamjährig aus umweltberaters
schaffet ist Präsident von dem Museum
hier hab viel neu über die kulturelle
Geschicht von wzaska Leh eine V der
durust stellige sorglose Kindheit
befasst sich mit der globale
Kinderarbeit und dem Fall von der wzaska
chemer Kinder der verfilm V V meistassen
Jugendbücher die schwarzen Brüder F
Geschicht in
sonon Armut Verkaufer Familie won aus
chemer in
Norditalien kennen le vi wer
geschickt für Lorenz sonini die
aufkigsarbeit vom Museum
perslicheheit nostra
responsabil dimenare storia D storia
nostra storia me laorare al Museo
derat engiert sich für vi proekt Region
so verkehrsenas
mobile
wasseras
sondern
entlang Wasserfall
fr
biserstal wi mit
Demut
[Musik]
der ob abkage li Lorenzo sononini s ganz
persönliche
Perle
Alero jeder Sommer W mit Familie DAH sch
[Musik]
Jahr
es ist ein magischer Ort übero man her
Wasserperlen irgendwo in der hö von der
lepontinische AE entspringt das Wasser
und sammelt sich un um sich später mit
der wzas
Vermis
n
noredealdinolutamente l'unicit D
verz per me veramente rpresenta ilore
ilore
affettivoici Lorenzo
Ursprung Ken besser
zu ab und doch mit dem Rest von der Welt
verbunden
vas
W
bore
zurück
finde die letzte zwe Etappen vor die n
startet am Lago maoreero
und Ponte Brolla auf der und letzte
Etappe V ma bis nach pa re aber nachas
undeson
und
speziortze n Pass endet die Race wo
unterhalb vom adfang und ganze Desin
geführt
h am Südostufer vom lagore auf dutsch
übrigens langesee zieht sich vor der
italienische Grenze über 10 km bis
sefang Riviera del gambaronno
[Musik]
hier stammt LT im Wasser wie NI anders
besit auf der für das auf die andere
[Musik]
Cent
sportiv Perle hier der Region
frü schulager oder Trainingslager mit
dem Fußball und auf de Platz von
trainerdipom
absolviert mer 40 Sportart Sport und
ausbildszentrum vom bundesamport ausüt
werde verfügt über 160
Sportanlage es ist zemes national
leisungszentrum für sportarte fußbau
kunstorne Dennis und schwimmen und jetzt
kann mch zu W ist wie die momentane
Perle im
Wassersport Beck trainiert ein von der
zurzit beste Schwimmer von der Welt das
Wasser h neue Ponti zu ein V dervg
schwömmer in der Geschicht vom Schwizer
schwmmsport
geformet s wichtigste Medaille überhaupt
gewint
2021 der olympische sommerspiel Tokio
der Shootingstar ha über 100 m
Schmetterling
Bronze e Jahr später schwimmt gerade
Europameisterschaft Rom über 100 m
Delfin zu
silberamente è bello Diver FTO qu
important SPO che si solo l'inizio di
una di una bella S
perors
noaeo piscinaa
laitatoare p vari n Lago da picolo prima
non ci andavo tanto d'accordo sì facevo
il bagno però nel Lago do non vedi il
fondo andavo un po' se Ando un po' oltre
la ne trainiert pro Woche rund 25 Stund
studiert Physiotherapie und S großer
folg V Sponsor Termin zum ander vi freiz
für
Region
fre
bef
gerade und verzweigt Ponte Brolla die
Landschaft vi W wo ger
wasserkumpe ist das ETW für dich ich
denke nicht der Körper vom
2jährige capital im Swimmingpool füht
sich W und sicher in der Natur h wei
nicht immer was unter
dererfl trotzdem som magisch Ort
Erlau
mitorsicht minuniotria
[Musik]
quante
dig
recupare che posso fare
qucaòoo
checiouto èo
non in questo momento della mia vitaenso
che sia necessario fare qualche
sacrificio non la vivo Male di sicuro
per sicuramente perché alla fine faccio
quello che mi piace quindi faccio
sacrificiit
Züge W sportlich
Karriere
[Musik]
für mir geht mal mat der bizarre
Schlucht entlang
witer floss wird da
breiter und man reicht gemint
maa mit ihrem wasserfau kaskada del
Salto Momente wo man sich z mus und
Zauber vor
Natur
wir und um sich mit der Energie
verbinden
50 km lang und hört in Basko
auf
hier W
laviz
und am
naturbeas wartet an
sie ist bekannt a Kommissarin von der TV
Kri datort schuspielere Wurzel imessin
Mut von Lugano
ihus mit dem hat sie mat wenn ich ins
Tessin bin komme ich einfach jeden Tag
in solche Orten es macht mich ruhig und
entspannt es ist einfach magisch ist
wirklich so es klingt ein bisschen dumm
es ist wirklich
[Musik]
so der operteil V wallema ist
geologische
Schatztruhe das ist schwitzw die einzige
gagend wo Marmor abbaut wird der
pmor
[Musik]
Pier
ber
Familie von 4jährige Rom künstlerisch
begabtut zeich oder sogar Schmuck Herst
wir sind eine Künstlerfamilie aber ich
bin die Einzige ist nicht so gut mit
Hände aber es ist einfach
so dann
darf
ma
under bis
Profis mit Vers Material kstlerisch Entf
kursle Lilian hler fürt Anna Kunst
vom
Anna danke schön das alles beinhal was
für Bild bra vi
[Musik]
Michelangelos Hammer und me
anna versucht mal
Gefühl und verti sich ziemlich schnell
immer wie wie lange Arbeit gibt einen FL
oder und dieser Flow eigentlich ist
letztendlich auch wier bisschen die
Arbeit an dir selbst diese Arbeit da am
Stein interessant du machst etas
mit Prozess
kreativ her schaffe ein dann bei ihrem
eig
brfswg ich war Musikerin und dann ich
war Klavierlehrerin und dann ich habe
gedacht ich habe mir in 10 Jahr
vorgestellt und ich habe gedacht nein
das ist nicht nicht richtig etwas stimmt
nicht ich muss meine Kreativität an
anders benutzen ich habe einfach
aufgehört und wieder ab Null angefangen
und Schauspielschule gemacht und ich war
schon 24 Anna du bist jetzt da was du
weißt nicht so recht glaube ich neh an
ich wo lang gehen und ich glaube im Stei
also in der Stei Bearbeitung ist extrem
wichtig dass du immer Entscheidig
triffst das ist e krass du musst
permanent entscheiden nicht da
nicht ja voil und ich habe ganz viele
Fehler gemacht sehr große Fehlern
gemacht und ich habe auch falsche Weg
genommen aber wenn man mit se intu
verbunden bleibt dann
einfach man findet den
Weg Anna und führt we V aber
durar zurück in
baskoona vor der St und steinig im
Gesam einzigartig mit
typis
im Sommer
bewohnt ganz FLI
bonaer wo Regionen prägt und D führt
Wasser wo mschezieht und Kultur vereint
wie hier im wasserf
volio
mit Fran geboren B
verliebt mit
fang wo über wasserperle zu andere Perle
vinführt und wertvoll wie Wasser ist für
sprach es anders
Verb
danti Mita sentire
senti
nocestir
r die gch im sonnerkanton von der
schwitz nimmt derfang V im Gebiet
Leventina der
Vino das Wasser Kanton
[Musik]
name
letzte Schritte über B über auf Neues
terin was ganz anderser men PRT was
andere
begnündige im
[Musik]
Wallis bist du Verb
ja aber die was nicht oder ne noch nicht
ganz
das S das schon
magis aber sage da
un
ganzig d entlang vi
abentür
entlang off für die neue
[Musik]
ab
ه